Bud
Ban
[Música]
সнаัง
பбan
[Música]
Paman
saran.
[Música]
சரனாமி
தய
பிบமி
தயாதமான
[Música]
கமித்தன
Gami
namasa
bagavat
sambuda.
[Música]
perdu
sex
[Música]
Gaan
scheing
corrand.
[Música]
sexма
Candrela
[Música]
sexo sol
guru perma
[Música]
no reino por do espaço básico dos
fenômenos livre de elaborações
na esfera da natureza dos fenômenos.
Além dos três tempos, além do princípio
do fim, está a corporificação da suprema
bem-aventurança,
espontaneamente perfeita e completa,
além de qualquer sentido de algo a ser
feito, presença semelhante ao céu,
preconceitos ou inclinações.
Suplico ao lama como darmacaia.
Suplico a Ord Pandun.
No reino puro doxtase supremo e
espontaneamente realizado,
estão as corporificações dos sugatas da
forma, fala, qualidades e atividade
dotados com cinco aspectos da sabedoria
primordial,
revelando-se individualmente como as
faces da presença compassiva.
Suplico ao lama como sambogakcaia.
Suplico a Ordemuni.
No reino da pureza inata deste mundo
pleno de sofrimento, surgindo através da
suprema compaixão pelo bem-estar dos
seres, emanações agem para beneficiar os
seres através dos meios háis de todas as
formas possíveis. Suplico aos lamas
comunir manacaias dos três tempos,
passado, presente e futuro. Suplico a
ordemuni
emar comampo do darmacaia o bud da sexta
família vajadara
o mestre vajassatva
o vitorioso e realizado rei dos sáquias
o senhor protetor amitaos e a
valoctesvara
ó pema que é inseparável deles a você o
rogo mandiuria mantaca e ass de sua
forma. O grande poderoso rai é a síndice
de sua fala,
>> é a síndice de sua mente. Ó guro, joia
que realiza desejos, a você o rogo.
Tetsou gueriruca corp purifica o
irresistível esplendor de suas
qualidades.
A forma de Doron é a síntese de sua
atividade.
de Alpo é o chefe das mãos e daquines.
Ó grande, glorioso trotensal,
a você o rogo. No espaço básico de sua
forma está a exibição mágica, o campo
das deidades pacíficas e iradas. A
melodia de sua fala corporifica os 12
ramos dos ensinamentos do Buda. A
intenção iluminada de sua mente permeia
toda parte desobstruída e penetrante.
Ó Senhor, chefe das daquines, a você o
rogo. Você profetizou a vinda de seus
regentes, escondeu representações de sua
fala como terma. Direcionou então sua
iluminada de sua mente para seus filhos
de carma fortunado e deixou seu
testamento com toda a nação tibetana.
Ó benevolente nirmanacaia,
a você o rogo. Recordo-me de sua
bondade, guru pochê. Rogo que você honre
o seu compromisso de nos guiar com sua
intenção iluminada nesses tempos
escuros.
Não ser você. Olhe por nós com
compaixão. Ó nermanacaé de ordem. Afaste
os distúrbios e disputas desses tempos
malévolos com sua força da de energia.
Rogo que nos conceda bênção, sabedoria
primordial iniciações.
Rogo, que enriqueça a força dinâmica das
nossas experiências de meditação e da
nossa realização.
Dote-nos totalmente com o poder e
habilidade de expandir os ensinamentos e
beneficiar os seres e leva-nos à
realização do estado búdico em uma só
vida.
que quer que apareça de fato como
objetos visíveis ao olho, tudo no mundo
externo, embora apareça, descanse sem
tomar isso como sendo real. A
purificação da percepção dualista é a
forma clara, porém vazia da deidade.
Suplico ao lama do desejo e do apego
naturalmente liberados. Suplico a ordem
que quer que ressoe de fato como objetos
perceptíveis ao ouvido, todos os sons
percebidos como agradáveis ou
desagradáveis.
Descanse
>> livre do pensamento especulativo,
a união do som vacuidade, além do
princípio do fim, é a fala dos
vitoriosos.
Suplico a fala dos vitoriosos, a união
do som com a vacuidade.
Suplico a ordem permun
que surja de fato como objetos na
imaginação.
Não importando quais pensamentos surjam
dos cinco venenos emocionais,
não permita que somente os antecipe,
siga-os ou se entregue a eles. Ao
permitir que este movimento descanse em
sua própria base, você é livre no
darmacaia.
Suplico ao lama da sabedoria intrínseca
naturalmente livre. Suplico a Oran
Padiun
externamente a pureza das coisas
percebidas como sendo objetos externos.
internamente a liberdade da natureza da
mente percebida como sendo o sujeito
interno. Entre estes o reconhecimento da
verdadeira face da lucidez total.
através da compaixão dos tatárgatas dos
três tempos, possa me ser concedida a
bênção que liberta meu fluxo mental,
uma ramudra da visão e a natureza básica
da mente, com nada para provar ou
dissipar. permita que sua natureza
básica se estabeleça sem fixações.
Esse é uma ramudra do estado meditativo.
A própria base amadurecida até o fruto.
Isso é uma ramudra da fruição, de modo a
gerar uma cadeia de bênçãos ao marram do
treinamento.
Agora, esta é a instrução para encontrar
a mãe da armata através dos seis selos.
aparência,
>> o selo da vacuidade.
Cele a vacuidade com as aparências
cele ambas com não dualidade de
aparência e vacuidade.
Cele essa não dualidade com a grande
bemaventurança.
Cele a grande bem-aventurança com a
ausência de pensamentos.
>> Ausência de pensamentos
>> o selo de mutável da armata.
Durante os cinco tipos de estados do
bardo, você deveria reconhecer a esfera
absoluta durante o bardo desta vida,
como uma criança perdida reencontrando
sua mãe. Esclarecer o que não estiver
claro reconhecer sua natureza durante o
bardo do Samad, como uma garota vaidosa
olhando para um espelho. Conectar as
tendências habituais com o samáo durante
o bardo do sonho como o fluxo de um rio.
Continuar a experiência durante o bardo
do nascimento e da morte. Como
reconectar um cano de água quebrado,
conectar com karma residual durante o
bardo do viracer. Como acender uma
lâmpada e um quarto escuro.
O profundo estágio da perfeição envolve
direcionar a lança de sua energia
lucidez combinadas
exclusivamente ao rum vermelho em seu
coração.
Demônios, impedimentos e espíritos
despeitados e malévolas. Todos eles nada
mais são do que manifestações mentais.
Reconheça a mente livre de
características.
Vacuidade e luminosidade são um absoluto
doredrolo.
Não o procure em outro lugar além dessa
sabedoria primordial
sem intermediários.
Grande Senhor presente
>> do Nirvana, retorna a esse lugar
grandioso e primordial de repouso.
Passado já cessou e o futuro ainda não
surgiu. Traga esta consciência para o
presente como consciência vazia, sem
intermediários para o caminho. Dessa
forma, se você alcançar estabilidade a
partir da familiarização,
uma vez que todos os fenômenos com
características foriam trapassados,
o glorioso Heruca será manifestado.
A sublime corporificação da sabedoria
primordial, a mandala natural. Assim
como a lua cheia é isenta de
elaborações,
como o brilho do sol, sua grandeza se
expressa em todos os lugares igualmente.
Rogo que se aproxime, atenda-me e
continue presente. Esta homenagem a
inexprimível sabedoria, o imutável
darmacaia, as deidades principais das
cinco famílias do supremamente
bem-aventurado Sambocaia,
exibição expansiva das deidades
pacíficas eiradas, a compaixão
manifestando-se abelmente como neranaia.
Efetivamente, na minha imaginação,
eu arrumo as nuvens de superáveis
oferendas de Samanta Badra, como uma
exibição completa por toda a vasta
amplitude do espaço básico em toda a sua
pureza. Eu lhes apresento este oceano de
oferendas externas, internas e secretas.
O ventre secreto de Contuzo. Toda vasta
profusão de todas as mandalas dos
vitoriosos tem um só sabor. A
>> possam se deleitar com a não dualidade
da mente desperta. A natureza da mente é
o vasto céu do espaço básico dos
fenômenos. Os fenômenos são totalmente
puros, atemporais, na lucidez total. A
imersão no ser genuíno é o espaço
básico, além da palavra e do conceito.
Sempre reverenciou a mente desperta como
sendo a igualdade disto. A contidos na
suprema e atemporal perfeição de cunto
zampo estão os arranjos das mandalas
externa, interna e secreta. A pureza
inerente do mundo das aparências e das
possibilidades
é o espaço básico das deidades
masculinas e femininas. Tudo que ocorreu
e ocorrerá é a perfeição espontânea
desses pais e mães com sortes em união.
A própria deusa corporifica o supremo
segredo do completo deleite no vótese de
seu lottus que avasta a expansão do
espaço básico. A lucidez total é a
esfera suprema da não dualidade.
Caia não fabricado sem adornos que a
essência da iluminação.
que aquja são as imutáveis deidades do
êxtase supremo. nessa mandala secreta
que está além da união e da separação,
supremas corporificações,
as deidades masculinas e femininas das
cinco famílias, bodissátuas, deidades
iradas, deusas vajas, senhores da
assembleia, mestres da congregação,
os seres grandes e gloriosos das cinco
famílias, os 10 reis da e suas
consortes, as deidades que Simbolosis e
regiões sagradas, as quatro deusas
guardiãs dos portões, as muitas deidades
congregadas que são emanações da
sabedoria primordial.
Aquelas deusas que, meigas como mães e
amorosas como irmãs, delineiam o certo e
o errado, e assim fazem cumprir o
Samaia.
Ó congregação de daquines externas e
internas e yoguines, testemunhas que
mantém os juramentos vágra, rogo que me
atendam.
Um nós, ridens herdeiros da compaixão,
fizemos brotar bodetite em benefício dos
seres e para alcançar um estado
insuperável,
seguimos as disciplinas do vasto oceano
de ensinamentos.
Os votos sublimes que une a forma fala
em mente iluminadas.
As obrigações vagas que para sempre
compromete não devem ser danificadas.
São samaias especiais, tanto genéricos
quanto específicos.
Aceitei e jurei
agora e no futuro. Não os danificarei ou
abandonarei. No entanto, embora sem
intenção de desviar-me deles ou
renegá-los por causa de preguiça e
procrastinação na prática, não
>> e minha energia diminui. Sem ter estado
atento, tornei-me negligente.
Não me empenho na meditação e minha
atenção vagueia durante os estágios da
aproximação e da consumação.
Desce de outras formas, devido ao poder
do reconhecimento,
eu me afastei consciente e
inconscientemente das instruções e
compromissos que recebi de meus mestres.
Nenhum Yog deveria jamais se associar à
aqueles que danificaram samaia, nem por
um instante. Essas são palavras do Buda,
mas sou incapaz de ser fiel a elas. A
entrada secreta é malograda, portanto,
torna-se difícil perceber as coisas com
qualquer clareza. E sem insite, não
percebo quem tem essas faltas.
Associei-me à aqueles que danificaram
samaia, multiplicando meus próprios
erros. Expliquei o dharma aqueles que
danificam samaia e aqueles que não são
receptores adequados. Ao não evitar
danos, tornei-me imaculado.
Acompanhe-me daqueles que danificam
samaia e assim manchei-me com as máculas
e contaminações dos danos. Arrependa-me
inteiramente pelas condições que me
impedem nessa vida e que me criarão
obscurecimentos no futuro. Reconheço-os
e confessoos com cheia de remorço.
Atendo-me com suave bondade amorosa.
Estabeleça-me firmemente para que eu
nunca do espaço básico.
Embora vocês vivem e comanimidade não
referencial,
por favor, concedeme a absolução suprema
da não dualidade.
A verdade última, além da elaboração,
não permite nenhum referencial baseado
no pensamento discursivo.
Enanto, se houver quaisquer erros devido
à mera ilusão da verdade relativa,
arrependo-me sinceramente
e rogo pela sua clemência.
Um cuntampo,
budo original na imediação da base do
ser. Vajra Satva que alcançou imutável
estado da talidade.
Grande herói, Senhor protetor que provê
refúgio aos seres. Atenda-me com sua
bondade e olhe por mim com o seu olho de
sabedoria primordial.
Ah, embora tudo seja primordialmente não
nascido e totalmente puro desde o
princípio, padrões de pensamento que
tudo permeiam, surge adventicamente no
rastro da confusão.
Esses, por sua vez, levam à ignorância,
percepção dualista, a aparências
condicionadas e dano e rompimento do
Samaia. Confesso tudo isto dentro da
vasta expansão da supremamente pura mãe,
que é o espaço básico dos fenômenos.
Vajra, samaia Vajra, conforme proclamado
por Vajrapan,
o senhor dos segredos, envolve centenas
de milhares de categorias de compromisso
Samaia da forma fala em mente. Por
qualquer dano que tal samaia e por
qualquer contradição às palavras dos
ensinamentos, eu tenho profundo remorço.
Conheço e confessoos com arrependimento.
Satua, uma vez passado o tempo de
purificar as faltas incorridas
daificação do Samaia, elas se tornam a
causa de reprovação irada por parte das
daquinesvagera que são encarregadas de
tal atividade.
Portanto, confesso tudo que trago
obscurecimentos nesta em vidas futuras e
que reforce as causas que conduzem aos
grandes infernos.
Um. O rei do desejo, supremo vagera
primordial, sem qualquer termo de
referência fixo a liberdade, além do
dano e da confissão.
Puntos amp é a vastidão da sabedoria
intrínseca perfeita desde o princípio.
dentro desta vastidão, o espaço básico
dos fenômenos, além da união e da
separação.
Ah,
nós passamos agora para as grandes
nuvens de bênçãos.
H,
hry,
no palácio do poder ardente de êxtase
supremo, reside as corporificações do
estado desperto primordial.
A união de êxtase e vacuidade.
Tendo a natureza do lottos desapegadas e
ao mesmo tempo inundadas de êxtase, elas
expressam a glória do supremamente
iluminador sol vágra. A metá do
dharmacaia, vagera darme loquesvara,
senhor do universo. Suas formas cor
purifica o envolvimento apaixonado da
compaixão inata.
Maguial, rei do lottos. Você exerce
domínio e poder sobre o sansário
Nirvana, como supremamente poderoso
Eruca, que subjulga o mundo de todas as
aparências e possibilidades através do
esplendor.
São vagabar e tcharvara e tacaraja, rei
do desejo. Vocês permanecem como
tesouros do êxtase supremo. por cul que
cativa as mentes de todos que existem
sem exceção.
Você é rica com o poder dos sinais
comuns e do sublime e dança em êxtase e
vacuidade.
Legiões de Dacas e Daquines Vajgara que
executam as atividades de poder na
esfera da igualdade, a união de
aparência e vacuidade.
fazem com que os três planos da
existência condicionada tremam com a
dança de suas formas várias. Vocês
sentimos os três reinos com o som de sua
gargalhada, sua fala iluminada
incessante.
Aios de luz vermelha permeiam todo
sansário nirvana, fazem vibrar e atraem
a essência vital da existência
condicionada e a paz definitiva.
Enquanto concede o mais sublime dos
desejos, o duplo cid da mente iluminada
da suprema paixão vagera. Com seus
grandes ganchos e laços vágra, vocês
unem o mundo de todas as aparências e
possibilidades emas e supremo.
Dançarinos no jogo da teia da ilusão
mágica ilimitada que preenche um espaço
até o transbordamento,
como rompimento de uma bolsa de gergim,
toda a vasta legião das três raízes,
hoste e deidades do poder. vocês rezo
com devoção.
Confiro nos suas bênçãos. Confiro-nos o
s de conquistar o poder desimpedido
sobre a infinita glória, realizações
sublime e da sublime.
Nós passamos agora pra prece de ordem.
Namor guru vitorioso das 10 direções e
dos quatro tempos e seus herdeiros
espirituais,
hostes de lamas, idans daquines e
protetores do dharma, a todos vocês, sem
exceção, tão numerosos quanto os átomos
do universo, rogo que se aproximem,
repousem sobre assentos de lotos e
discos de lua no céu à minha frente.
Presta homenagem com devoção de corpo,
fala em mente. A vocês faço oferendas
externas, internas e secretas. e a
oferenda da talidade.
A presença dos sugatas supremos expresso
remorço por minhas muitas ações nocivas
do passado. Confesso com arrependimento
minhas ações desvirtuosas atuais e
juro-me abster de futuras más ações.
Egozijo-me com todas as acumulações de
mérito e de virtude. Suplico as hóstas
de vitoriosos que não passem para o
nirvana final e que ao invés disso gire
a roda das três coleções do dharma e dos
ensinamentos insuperáveis.
Dedico todas as minhas ações virtuosas,
sem exceção a todos os seres. Que eles
possam atingir um nível da insuperável
liberação.
Ó Budas, seus herdeiros espirituais,
atend-me, assim como compôs essa
excelente prece
Mulando vitorioso Samanta Badra, seus
herdeiros espirituais e o grandioso
onisciente Mandurce. Possa eu treinar,
segundo seus exemplos, que os lamas
preciosos, o esplendor dos ensinamentos
possam estar em todos os lugares como o
espaço, possam iluminar todos os lugares
como o sol e a lua, possam ser sempre
estáveis como uma montanha. Que a
preciosa sanga, fundação dos
ensinamentos,
possa ser enriquecida pelo
companheirismo, disciplina pura e os
três treinamentos mais elevados, que
aqueles que praticam o mantra secreto, a
essência dos ensinamentos,
possam manter samaia e levar os estágios
do desenvolvimento e da consumação à
culminância.
Que os domínios dos reis dármicos,
protetores e patos dos ensinamentos
possam se expandir e prosperar. Que os
nobres ministros servidores da doutrina
possam possuir crescente inteligência e
acuidade. Que os ricos chefes de
família, patrocinadores dos
ensinamentos,
possam gozar de prosperidade e ficar
livres do mal. E todos aqueles em todas
as nações que tiverem fé nos
ensinamentos
possam ser felizes e que seus obstáculos
possam ser pacificados.
Além disso, que nós e que seguimos este
caminho, possamos dandonificar nossa
maia e alcançar nossos objetivos. Que
todos aqueles com quem tivemos boas e
más conexões cármicas possam ser
abraçados pelos vitoriosos agora e no
final. Que todos possam ingressar pela
porta do caminho inigualável e alcançar
o domínio supremo de CTO Zambro.
Nós passamos agora pra prática de Tara.
[Música]
Dedicamos nossa prática todos os budas e
patriarcas que mantiveram
a luz do dharma por inúmeras gerações,
aos benfeitores e benfeitoras do dharma,
vivos e falecidos,
aos nossos ancestrais e a todos os seres
que morreram para nossa sobrevivência.
Dedicamos nossa prática às pessoas vivas
e à pessoas falecidas aqui relacionadas,
para que com uma luz que dissipa a
escuridão,
o avorecer de darmate e das cinco
sabedoria se complete, conduzindo-as à
liberação das enfermidades, aflições e
confusão, e capacitando-as
a agir em benefício de todos os seres.
Dedicamos a lucidez e a realização de
todos os seres em todas as direções e
templos. Que todos encontrem a
felicidade e as causas da felicidade
e superem o sofrimento e as causas do
sofrimento.
Nós vamos dedicar, a gente se encontra
hoje para fazer essa prática, dedicando
especialmente a remoção de obstáculos do
Ricardo Aveline.
E queria agradecer a Sanga que tá
presente e a Sanga também que tá à
distância online, né? E
sempre lembrando que enfim os três
refúgios são abudo darme a sangue, né?
Sendo que como a gente, como os mestres
tibetanos gostam de lembrar, a o Buda
veio, mas ele foi, né?
Então, super importante a gente entender
que há esse milagre extraordinário, que
é o fato de que a sangue
então a sanga, desde o tempo do Buda, a
sangue, né? Então isso é muito
maravilhoso. Então, nós tomamos refúgio
no Buda, que nós podemos ver como a num
aspecto externo como a figura histórica
do Buda, num aspecto interno como a
sabedoria natural que brota diante das
aparências
e no aspecto secreto como a a natural
liberdade incessantemente presente
e que é Como
eu acho mais fácil explicar isso através
de imagens, né? Como num céu noturno,
nós vemos as estrelas e vemos os
planetas e vemos a lua, mas há o céu
escuro atrás disso, né? Silencioso.
Quanto as estrelas mudam,
aparentemente elas se deslocam.
Ainda assim, nós vemos
que o céu tá incessantemente presente
com uma grande abertura onde tudo se
manifesta,
né? Isso também para os meditantes.
É como nós sentamos em silêncio
e nós experimentamos esse silêncio
interno e o nosso silêncio acompanha
todo o som que a gente possa produzir.
Mas enquanto o som ele vem e vai, o
silêncio segue. Mas o silêncio é vivo. O
silêncio não é algo vazio. O silêncio é
vivo.
E além desse silêncio, que a gente possa
experimentar quando nós praticamos
meditação,
a um silêncio não construído atrás desse
próprio silêncio, né?
Então, nós temos esse desafio de
reconhecer esse aspecto secreto, não
elaborado, incessantemente presente, que
não atua no tempo. Ah, por exemplo,
quando nós meditamos, aí surge o
silêncio. Então, esse silêncio, num
certo sentido, ele também surge e depois
cessa, mas há um silêncio que não é
construído, incessantemente presente.
Então esse é o aspecto secreto.
Na
nos ensinamentos dentro do Surangama
sutra, o Buda descreve
para o rei Brazenag,
que tava um pouco ansioso porque ele se
sentia envelhecendo, né?
E
eu achei aquilo um pouco que o rei tava
um pouco estressado assim, porque ele
não tinha nem 76 anos, já tava ansioso
assim, né? Mas aí o rei tava um pouco
aflito assim e aí ele pergunta pro Buda
isso, o que que se preserva além de vida
e morte, né? E o Buda dá uma resposta
que eu acho assim completamente
maravilhosa, né? Mas ela não é muito
fácil de entender.
Então ele ele pergunta pro Buda se ele
lembra quando ele às vezes que ele
esteve no
eh vendo o rio Ganjas, né, que é um rio
sagrado da Índia. Então eles de modo
geral faziam peregrinações até o rio
Ganjos.
E
então o rei para disse: "Sim, eu lembro
quando a minha mãe me levou numa numa
que era uma época de uma festa, ela me
levou até o rio quando eu era pequeno.
Aí depois eu voltei em diferentes
momentos
e o Buda pergunta para ele: "E como que
você viu o rio?
E se alterou esse processo de ver o rio
se alterou? Eu acho que o o rei
Przenajet ouvido muitos ensinamentos
porque ele deu a resposta certa, né?
Então ele vai dizer que não se alterou a
forma como ele viu. As palavras elas
surgem como se fosse assim: "E o rio?" O
rio era igual. O rio era igual, mas o
ponto é a visão do rio.
Então esse ponto ele é um ponto muito
curioso assim, né? Por exemplo, nós
olhamos gruh puxando na parede ali, né?
Olhamos área tara naquele outro painel,
né? É assim. E a gente vê gruinho pochê,
vê a área tara, mas eh eu acho que
muitos de vocês que estavam aqui no
período que a Titi tava pintando, vocês
ajudaram a pintar também, né? Acho que
vários de vocês estavam ajudando aqui.
Então vocês sabem que ninguém colocou
guru rooch no painel. pessoal só colocou
tinta,
portanto nós não nós vemos a tinta e
vemos guru pochê. Então isso é o aspecto
luminoso da mente. Nós olhamos as luzes
e vemos muito mais do que as luzes.
Então quando o rei Prinagit foi lá e
olhou o rio, ele construiu o rio com a
sua mente. Outros seres podem ter outras
experiências, como os pássaros, os
próprios peixes, e outros seres podem
ter outras experiências. E ele também
outros momentos ele passou lá, ele viu o
próprio rio, mas ele construiu o rio que
ele viu. Então esse aspecto luminoso,
ele ele segue intacto, ele não muda além
ao longo do tempo.
Na visão budista, esse aspecto
profundo é descrito como darmata.
Então, o Buda num aspecto
mais grosseiro, ele é visto como a sua
aparência física.
Também no aspecto sutil, ele é visto
como os ensinamentos, mas no aspecto
secreto, ele é esse aspecto luminoso que
faz as aparências e os mundos todos
surgirem, né? Então esse é um ponto eh
crucial assim. E
quando nós compreendemos isso, nós
compreendemos também os seis bardos. Nós
compreendemos como nós estamos agora no
bardo da vida,
como à noite nós experimentamos o bardo
do sonho.
O bardo do sonho ele se assemelha muito
ao bardo da vida, porque como o bardo da
vida agora nós temos essa experiência e
aparentemente nada falta, não falta
nada, nós estamos imersos aqui, né?
Então, do mesmo modo, no bardo do sonho,
quando nós estamos imersos no sonho, nós
não temos a sensação de que a gente tá
no lugar errado, tem alguma coisa
faltando. Nós estamos imersos naquelas
experiências. Então, quando nós estamos
em experiências desse modo que surgem,
excessam e elas ocupam inteiramente a
nossa mente, nós chamamos isso de
bardos. Mas esses bardos eles são
manifestos luminosamente.
Isso com o bardo do sonho. As imagens
aparecem, os nossos medos, as nossas
alegrias aparecem e a nossa identidade
aparece também.
Ainda assim, não há propriamente uma
realidade tangível disso, né? Mas a
nossa mente ela ocupa esse lugar. Se o
Buda vivesse nesse tempo, eu acho que
ele ia também descrever os bardos das
telas, né? Porque nós podemos, olhando
filmes, nós podemos também entrar em
outros mundos e ter emoções e ter
sensações de perda, de ganho e ficarmos
totalmente polarizados.
E se alguém nos chamar para fora
daquilo, a gente também não quer, porque
aquilo é algo que domina a nossa mente,
né?
Então, esses são bardos, são situações
desse tipo, né? Então, o Buda mostra
como dentro de cada bardo, as aparências
que surgem, elas são luminosas, elas não
precisam ser reais, como o bardo do
sonho, né? Então, do mesmo modo, o bardo
da meditação,
muitos praticantes não gostam de ouvir
que a meditação é um bardo também, né?
Se nós não tivermos uma lucidez
verdadeira, nós temos estados
transitórios
que eles vão ser descritos como mundo da
forma, o mundo da não forma, né? O Buda
vai descrever isso. Ele vai descrever
muitos diferentes estados, pelo menos 20
diferentes estados meditativos,
que são estados delusivos que pertencem
ao mundo da forma e da não forma. São
bardos, bardos da meditação. Então nós
entramos na meditação,
experimentamos por um tempo e depois
sucessa,
né? Esse critério do bardo, ele no caso
do budismo, ele é essencial, porque nós
estamos buscando silêncio que não é
construído. Estamos buscando o céu
profundo que não é construído.
Nós estamos procurando o aspecto
secreto, que é a própria manifestação do
Buda, que não surge, não cessa.
Portanto, quando nós entendemos os
bardos, a gente compreende que há nele
neles um nível de surgimento,
permanência e sensação. Portanto, há
nisso um nível de delusão, né? Esse
aspecto é um pouco desesperador pros
praticantes,
porque os praticantes buscam esse estado
final, essa condição final, ah, que não
é necessário fazer esforço, que é um
ponto final, né?
E e esse é o ponto central também do
Buda, mas nós vamos fazendo nossas
práticas e a gente vai fazendo as
práticas e descobrindo que ali são
bardos, são estados transitórios, né?
Então o Buda quando vai descrever os
seis bardos, ele escreve o bardo da
vida, o bardo do sonho, o bardo da
meditação, mas ele vai descrever também
o bardo do morrer, né? Bardo do morrer é
de grande importância, pessoal. Grande
importância. Se a pessoa tiver sorte,
ela pode experimentar o barto do morrer
por um tempo.
Porque quando
a nossa mente
ela, a gente poderia definir assim, né?
Buscar encontrar uma definição pro bardo
do morrer, porque o bard do morrer não é
o bardo onde a pessoa tá imediatamente
morrendo, é o é um bardo.
Obrigado Tatã.
Então, o bardo do morrer é uma condição
que a gente poderia dizer assim: "A
pessoa, se alguém disser o que que você
vai fazer nas férias?" A pessoa diz:
"Olha, eu eu não tenho mais como pensar
em férias,
né? Porque eu não sei quanto tempo mais
eu vou viver. Eu tô tô morrendo, eu tô
muito doente",
né? Aí a pessoa diz: "Você não tinha um
projeto que você queria comprar uma casa
ou queria alguma coisa, fazer uma
viagem?" Pensou: "Eu tô cancelei esses
projetos porque, enfim, eu vou vou
pensar nisso como, né? E no ano que vem
você faria o quê?" Pou: "Eu não quero
pensar no ano que vem porque eu não
tenho mais ano que vem, né?" E eu pensei
em você pra gente aprender chinês,
tibetano, sânscrito, pale. Pois é. Eu
acho que eu não sou parceiro, isso eu
deixo pra próxima vida,
porque a pessoa ela eu não tenho como
ficar pensando pra frente. Então nós de
modo geral temos sempre alguma coisa
para fazer, né? Eu diria assim que o
bardo da eh decreptitude, o bardo da
velice e da morte, eles se aproximam
porque eles não têm um futuro
propriamente, né? É assim.
Então eu acho essa definição super
importante. Então nós não temos mais
aquilo, não temos que pensar paraa
frente. Então no período do bardo da
morte, as imagens do passado começam a
retornar assim com força, né? Porque a
pessoa ela tem uma aspiração de encerrar
bem o que ela precisa encerrar. Então
ela olha para trás e vê ovo, deixei isso
para trás e deixei aquilo. Então tem que
resolver isso, tem que resolver aquilo.
A pessoa fica
tentando equilibrar o que ela já fez,
né? Então isso é o bardo do morrer.
Portanto, ele é muito importante.
Então nesse período, nós temos um
processo de cura super importante. Então
na nossa linguagem aqui especialmente a
gente privilegia
a o metabávana, a prática de metabana,
meta e amor, bávana e meditação,
meditação universal. Ou seja, nós toda
lembrança, todo ser que aparece do
passado e toda a aparência que surge,
nós olhamos para esses seres e a gente
diz que eles sejam felizes, que eles
encontrem as verdadeiras causas da
felicidade,
superem o sofrimento e as verdadeiras
causas do sofrimento. Assim nós vamos
curando todas as relações,
né? E se a pessoa entender por que ela
deve fazer isso, ótimo. Se ela não
entender, ótimo, porque se ela fizer, é
o suficiente,
né? Então, quando nós fazemos a prática
eh a prática de metabalva, né? Eh, o
Tocu da San, que foi meu mestre Zen, ele
era muito gozado, ele segue gozado
porque ele tá vivo, ele é assim uma
pessoa maravilhosa, muito interessante,
né? Ele continua assim, imprevisível,
maravilhoso.
E toca da sã, ele era também um curador
ou é um curador, ele tá vivo, né? Ele
ele dava formação em medicina chinesa,
medicina japonesa.
E então ele ele dizia assim: "Quando a
pessoa tem uma doença muito grave, a
pessoa deve praticar metabara, né?
Se a pessoa praticar direito, ela cura
as relações. Quando a pessoa cura as
relações, a forma qual a energia circula
dentro do corpo se altera. Pode ser que
as doenças desapareçam.
Se não desaparecerem, pelo menos a
pessoa tem uma morte melhor, né? É
assim. Então isso é uma recomendação
muito muito adequada, muito favorável. E
esse é o tempo do
bardo do morrer. Então, se a pessoa
tiver algum tempo de bardo do morrer, é
melhor. Uma morte abrupta, ela não é
muito favorável, porque a gente não tem
tempo para consertar aquilo que ficou.
Então, então vocês vejam, quando nós
vamos consertando, o ambiente todo
sorri, ele começa a sorrir. Nós
começamos a nos sentir bem no ambiente
onde nós estamos. E é nesse lugar onde
nós estamos nos sentindo o aspecto sutil
desse lugar que nós vamos ter
renascimento depois,
né? Então nós vamos para esses lugares.
Se as pessoas tiverem, por exemplo, uma
capacidade de ampliar a visão, ampliar a
visão os ensinamentos, elas podem
simplesmente atingir a liberação no
momento da morte ou antes mesmo, né? E
elas podem não renascer, elas podem não
voltar simplesmente, né? Então isso é
considerado mais favorável. Eu acho que
paraa imensa maioria das pessoas eh há
essa aspiração, não, mas eu gostaria de
voltar, né? E há também um pouco de
ansiedade, assim, se eu não voltar, eu
fico aonde, né? Eu não sei se esse lugar
que eu vou, eu vou gostar, né? E se eu
não gostar, como é que eu faço, né?
Eu quero ter algumas garantias. Eu já
vi, por exemplo, o pessoal reclamando,
não, mas lá no céu da liberação, aquilo
é meio parado, né? Que não tem uma sexta
de noite pra gente sair assim, não tem
uma folga assim.
Pois é. Então essa é essa é a noção. Se
você aspira uma folga, pode ficar
tranquilo, né? Porque você não vai pro
lugar onde não há folga. Nós já vamos
para lugares onde tá cheio de movimento,
né? Só que o movimento
ele ele tem esse aspecto da das da roda
da vida, né? Como tá descrito ali no
painel, é a roda da vida. Esse é um
processo né?
Então aqui nós tomamos refúgio no Buda,
no darme na sanga, sendo que o refúgio
no Buda tem esses três aspectos: aspecto
grosseiro, aspecto sutil, aspecto
secreto. E o aspecto secreto é
justamente
a base livre da mente de onde nós
construímos as ideias, construímos as
coisas e nos movimentamos, né? Então, o
refúgio é o ponto inicial e é o último
ponto a ser atingido no caminho, né?
Curioso assim, porque a gente pensa,
bom, tomei refúgio no Buda, OK? Você
tomou o refúgio do jeito que você
consegue.
Então, a prática ao longo da vida ou das
vidas é melhorar o refúgio, né? Super
importante assim, aqui num templo sempre
tem um altar. No altar tem imagem do
Buda. Então se considera que os altares
eles são faróis paraas próximas vidas,
para essa vida e para as próximas, né? É
assim porque nós fazemos prostrações,
olhamos pros altares,
pros mestres, a gente sempre vai eh nós
vamos guardar quando na numa próxima
vida a gente cruzar pela frente de uma
porta assim, a gente dê uma olhada, diz:
"Pá, isso eu conheço, isso eu sei, né?
vai ter uma conexão. Então esse farol
ele vai nos atrair, nós vamos seguir as
nossas práticas, né? É assim. Então esse
é o ponto. Nós estamos assim, né? Então
nós tomamos refúgio no Buda, no Dharma e
na sanga. Então o Dharma também no
sentido externo, o dharma é o conjunto
dos textos, é o conjunto das lembranças,
é o conjunto das imagens, das histórias
contadas né?
No aspecto sutil, o dharma, ele já é a
nossa capacidade de olhar para as
aparências
como aparências
mágicas todas,
como por exemplo, nós estamos olhando
guru em pochê,
a gente podia dizer, bom, não há guru em
pochê
ali, né? Eles vão dizer, bom, o lama é
horrível assim, fica negando, fica
tirando a sacralidade da imagem. Não,
não é isso. É mais ainda, pessoal. Por
exemplo, quando nós olhamos a imagem e
vemos que a gente só colocou tintas, não
vou não vou dizer qual foi a marca da
tinta, é porque eu sei qual foi, né? Mas
não vou fazer propaganda aqui, né? Que
aliás tá durando essa tinta boa.
Então ah
nós colocamos tinta sobre o painel, mas
nós vemos guru rimchet. Então, vocês
vejam, esse é o guru rempoché no nível
sutil.
Ele aparece, nós vemos, ele é
inseparável do nosso coração,
inseparável da nossa mente. Então a
gente pensa, não, eu tô dessacralizando
a imagem, não, eu tô reconhecendo que a
imagem se tornou completamente mágica,
né? Então, nós temos esse olhar que é
capaz de ver. Do mesmo modo, quando nós
olhamos os textos, né, a gente podia
dessacralizar os textos. Nosso texto é
papel e um monte de risquinho.
Ali não tem nada.
Mas esse é o aspecto mágico, porque nós
pegamos papel e um monte de risquinho e
o nosso olho brilha e nós começamos
entender o que tá ali. Então esse é o
aspecto sutil do dharma.
O aspecto secreto do dharma é o lugar de
onde brota essa compreensão, que é o céu
profundo, que é o silêncio não
construído. De lá, quando nós olhamos as
aparências construídas, o fato de que
elas são construídas fica visível. Nós
vemos o mundo sendo construído
incessantemente né?
Então, o dharma, nós tomamos refúgio no
dharma também. Se a gente puder tomar
refúgio no dharma, eh, guardando os
livros mais importantes, como por
exemplo Surangama Sutra, que nós
publicamos, né, recentemente. Agora a
gente pretende publicar também o Sutra
do Lótus, como os nossos textos e muitos
outros textos, né? Se a gente puder
guardar isso, é maravilhoso. Mas mais
importante do que isso é entender os
conteúdos, ser capaz de olhar os
risquinhos e ver e e e intuir,
reconhecer o que tá ali, né? E o aspecto
secreto que é o silêncio que nós
cultivamos e justo porque nós olhamos
Deus do silêncio, então essa compreensão
é possível.
Aí nós temos a sanga, né? Aí nós tomamos
refúgio na sanga. Então vocês vejam a
sanga, pessoal, é super importante,
super importante, né? Maravilhosa.
Assim, nós sozinhos, muito difícil,
muito difícil. Eu vejo, vou olhando os
diferentes cébias, diferentes cidades,
né? Eu vou encontrando praticantes em
cidades grandes, eles estão muito
sozinhos. Ainda que eles tenham os
grupos e se reúnam de tanto em tanto, as
suas vidas estão desconectadas.
Por quê? Porque eles estão correndo,
fazendo as suas coisas no cotidiano,
eles não têm o tempo. Então, quando a
sangrutura,
ah, ela é uma manifestação maravilhosa
das 21as, como tão descritas ali, né?
Como são descritas no budismo tibetano,
21 manifestações femininas compassivas
e sábias. Então isso é maravilhoso.
Agora visitando, eu vou, eu vou contar
de novo,
visitando a Neia. Aí o que que o que que
a gente vê? A gente vê a Sanga cuidando
da Neia, né? Né? Que retornou do
hospital aqui. Feliz de ver ela bem
assim, né? E aí a Sanga toda entrando e
saindo na casa. Eu não sei como é que a
Néia acha que é bom tanta gente assim,
né? uma sanga tão numerosa
assim, mas é essa compaixão, esse amor
que vai que vai cuidando onde tem alguém
precisando de alguma coisa, aí já tem
uma guardiã do lado ali que não numa
ropa.
É assim,
eu também, né? Me sinto super acolhido
passando por esse período agora, né? A
sanga tá toda aqui,
né? Tá, tá ali, ó,
meus queridos. Eu tô vendo o pessoal lá
na Espanha
assim.
Aí me sinto Portugal. Não, não acredito.
João tá lá.
É assim.
Então, maravilhoso, nós estamos juntos,
nós nos apoiamos
e assim nós vamos andando, né? É assim.
Então, agradeço muito na nós estamos
vendo agora, hoje foi a missa de sétimo
dia, né? A minha filha Ana Cláudia,
minha querida, linda, né? Vamos deixar,
quer dizer, desculpa ter falado isso, eu
não queria ter mencionado, mas
éim né?
E fico super feliz também. Ela veio aqui
por esse dia super importante. Eu
agradeço. Ela não vai sair daqui
riscando
porque ela tem vários homens esperando
por ela,
os meninos todos, né, que ela tem que
E
ela hoje tava olhando, nós estávamos
olhando as faixas das várias oferendas
de flores que foram enviadas, né, muitos
diferentes CEBS. Assim, teve também o CB
Paris que foi o mais charmoso, assim,
não sei por chama fá sanga de Paris
assim, mas pelo menos a metade da
cidade né?
Super bonito. Então, a gente se sente
coração aquecido, né?
Quando as coisas complicam assim, quem é
que a gente chama? A gente chama sempre
a Dra. Marcele, né? Fazer o quê?
A Marcele se esconde assim, mas ela tá
sempre nos acompanhando e realmente
ajudando de uma forma delicada, de uma
forma assim pontual, certeira, né?
Maravilhosa. Queria agradecer também a
Marcele aqui que nos ajuda há muito
tempo né?
Então essa é uma riqueza que a gente não
sabe nem o que dizer, né? Porque uma
riqueza que vem do coração. Isso é muito
maravilhoso.
Então nós vamos nós vamos seguir a nossa
prática e nós estamos entrando
justamente nessa parte da prática
concisa de Tara Vermelha, né?
Hoje nós estamos na missa de sétimo dia.
Eu achei tão bonito lá uma menção a
Nossa Senhora que tava lá na imagem dela
ali do lado. Eu não quis dizer na hora
porque não tinha como falar, né? Mas
eles estão com essa ideia, essa coisa de
área tarde de Nossa Senhora assim, mas
com esse mesmo sentido, né, de uma uma
natureza compassiva incessantemente
presente, né? Eu ia dizer que a gente
tem 21 manifestações de Tara, mas de
Nossa Senhora tem muitas também, né? É
assim né?
E essas manifestações, elas são formas
de sabedoria que socorre os seres. O
ensinamento mais profundo disso é que
assim, todas as manifestações de Tara,
que são essencialmente compassivas, elas
brotam do grande silêncio e brotam do
grande do espaço
do céu profundo, né? É assim. que é o
aspecto primordial, né? Então, todas
essas manifestações, se nós quisermos
entendê-las, nós vemos elas brotando
desse lugar profundo, né? É assim.
Então, eh, essa prática é uma prática
que recupera,
porque nós podemos, por exemplo, pensar
que a compaixão é uma coisa nossa
pessoal dentro de nós, mas ela não é uma
coisa
pessoalizável.
A compaixão é algo que
eh que transcende isso, né? Então, a
compaixão
ela tá ligada à própria sanga.
A sanga já é uma manifestação
maravilhosa,
assim, né? Então, nós vamos fazer fazer
essa prática.
Nós aqui a gente tem que lembrar também,
agradecer Thiago Dibochet que trouxe
essa prática para nós e também Thago do
Cadro, a Lama Seren, que tem sustentado
essa prática dando as iniciações e
fazendo
a a sustentação incessante dos
ensinamentos né?
Então vocês vão reconhecer isso.
Obrigado Tatã.
Nós vamos reconhecer essa imagem assim,
eh, do espaço ou da vacuidade, surge a
manifestação de Tara, no sentido de que
do espaço ou da vacuidade surge a
própria compaixão,
assim,
como uma expressão desse aspecto
profundo né?
Espaço à minha frente, mãe de todos
vitoriosos. Tara de fato aparece a ela.
Eu rezo agora, enquanto eu incontáveis
outras pessoas, estamos perdidos no
oceano do sofrimento sansárico, busco a
iluminação para adquirir a felicidade
temporária definitiva para mim e para
todos os seres vivos. Por esse motivo,
tomo o refúgio em areatara, a
corporificação do puro estado desperto,
indissociável de todas as qualidades
perfeitas do Buda, dharma, sanga, lama,
idan e daquini. Do fundo do coração
rezo, evocando da testa, garganta e
coração de Tara, uma corrente brilhante
de luz nas cores do arco-íris.
À medida que os raios de luz tocam a mim
e a todos os outros seres, os frutos
venenosos do karma negativo, doenças,
aflições demoníacas e obstáculos
evaporam-se como orvalho sobre o sol da
manhã. Mérito, sabedoria, glória,
riqueza e longevidade
aumentam além de qualquer medida. Ó
ilustre Tara, por favor, tenha
consciência de mim.
Remova meus obstáculos e rapidamente
conceda minhas excelentes aspirações.
con
Pag
sun
Sand
[Música]
Pagma
Pag
sandu
[Música]
Sand
con
sandon
[Música]
taret.
Tra
Tá
so
tetar
tor
Tá
tão
tetar.
[Música]
Tutar
tare
T
on tare
tare
[Música]
umra.
os bilhões de universos, o monte Meru,
os quatro continentes, os continentes
menores, o esplendor e a glória dos
deuses nargas e humanos, juntamente com
suas raízes de virtude, emanam como
enormes e extensas nuvens e oferendas
perfeitamente puras. Eu as ofereço a
Tara, mãe dos vitoriosos.
Honom
os bilhões de universos, o monte Meru
quatro continentes, os continentes
menores, o esplendor e a glória dos
deuses naas e humanos, juntamente com
suas raízes de virtude, emanam como
enormes e extensas nuvens de oferendas
perfeitamente puras. Eu as ofereço a
Tara, mãe dos vitoriosos.
Hra
os bilhões de universos, o monte Meruz,
os quatro continentes, os continentes
menores, o esplendor e a glória dos
deuses naas e humanos, juntamente com
suas raízes de virtude, emanam como
enormes e extensas nuvens de oferendas
somente puras. Eu as ofereço a Tara, mãe
dos vitoriosos,
tranguro, ratna mandala edanam.
pela força dessa oração feito com o
coração, que a mente iluminada possa ser
conquistada e que as aparências possam
ser percebidas com pureza como sendo o
corpo da deidade, que o significado dos
estágios do desenvolvimento e da
consumação
possa ser naturalmente internalizado.
Que as condições não auspiciosas para o
caminho perfeito possam ser pacificadas.
E que todas as aspirações e condições
auspiciosas concebíveis possam ser
preenchidas.
Que máculas e obscurecimentos da não
virtude possam ser purificados
e que o mal proveniente de outros seres
e os sonhos ruins possam ser evitados.
Conceda a bênção da proteção para o medo
dos estados inferiores de existência.
nas oito condições onde não há
oportunidade para a prática, que todas
as vidas possam ser lembradas e que as
faculdades possam ser lúcidas, possa a
disciplina ser pura e a mente voltar-se
para o dharma contra o amadurecimento do
karma causado pelas ilusões, conceda a
bênção que escuda, protege e oculta. que
o poder adverso dos inimigos, demônios,
interferências fantasmagóricas,
os efeitos nocivos da morte
extemporânea,
epidemias e doenças causadas por venenos
possam ser todos pacificados e
purificados e que a sabedoria e as
atividades de Tara possam ser reveladas
no reino puro dos vitoriosos, que a
presença espontânea dos três caias
encontra Ela que dá nascimento aos
vitoriosos dos três tempos, uma nuvem
inexaurível com a felicidade dos três
segredos. Prosto-me diante de você, ó
guia sublime dos três reinos da
existência, a partir de agora e até que
alcance a iluminação,
>> como minha única fonte de refúgio,
proteção, de acordo com suas aspirações
e compromissos pregressos, não hesite em
sua compaixão.
Conceda plenamente a mim seus poderes,
bênçãos e sides. Todo aquele que me ver,
me ouvir, me tocar ou se lembrar de mim,
por que são quatro meios de liberação e
pelo mais sublimicide,
possa eu ser capaz de liberar todos que
estão ligados a mim e possa minha
realização tornar-se igual à sua, sem
recorrer ao poder da imantação. Como
poderia alguém adquirir as qualidades
necessárias para cuidar dos outros?
influenciar todos os seres a serem
pacificados,
positivos e negativos, sem exceção, ao
inspirar neles os quatro tipos de
devoção.
conquistar as qualidades positivas do
estado da liberação, que todos os seres
possam conseguir rapidamente a forma
efetiva dos vitoriosos,
resplandescente com as marcas maiores e
menores da perfeição.
até tal momento, possamos estar livres
dos oito grandes medos e de influências
malévolas, possam florescer qualidades
favoráveis, como longevidade, glória e
excelência. Que a yoga dos dois estágios
possa ser conquistada e que possamos
ficar livres de obstáculos. que em todos
os países a doença, guerra e fome,
>> que todos os seres possam possuir
alegria, felicidade sublime e praticar o
dharma. Que os ensinamentos do Boda
possam ser propagados e que todos os
seres possam se abrigar sob orientação
de Tara, mãe dos vitoriosos.
Que em todos os países a doença, guerra
e a fome possam ser pacificadas.
Que todos os seres possam possuir
alegria, felicidade sublime e praticar o
dharma. Que os ensinamentos do Buda
possam ser propagados.
Todos os seres possam se abrigar sob
orientação de Tara, mãe dos vitoriosos.
Que em todos os países a doença, guerra
e fome possam ser pacificados.
Que todos os seres possam possuir
alegria, felicidade sublime e praticar o
dharma. Que os ensinamentos do boda
possam ser propagados.
Sabrigar sob orientação de Tara, mãe dos
vitoriosos.
O apego às aparências comuns e a minha
forma corpórea se desfaz.
espaço da
>> espontaneamente o estado desperto
natural de minha mente com a sílaba raiz
tam de cor vermelha brilhante
instantaneamente tam se transforma na
forma luminosa da nobre Tara ela está
sorrindo e é extremamente bela sua mão
direita faz o gesto da suprema
generosidade
e segura um vaso de longa vida sua mão
esquerda faz o gesto das três joias e
segura pela aste uma flor de tupala
vermelha. Dentro das pétalas da flor há
um ar que flecha totalmente esticados,
feitos de delicadas flores. Suas vestes
são feitas.
>> Cobre com perfeição. Ela usa joias que
realizam desejos e ornamentos
esplêndidos, bem como uma guirlanda de
flores de lótos. Metade de seu cabelo
está preso no alto da cabeça. Metade cai
sobre as costas. Ela está sentada na
postura do conforto real, sobre um disco
do sol repousado sobre um lótus
vermelho. Uma lua cheia aparece por trás
dela. O budam está sentado sobre um
lótus acima de sua cabeça. Ela tem cor
vermelha como rubi. Seu brilho glorioso
se radia com as cores do arco-íris,
preenchendo uma esfera infinita. sobre
um lótus vermelho, um disco do sol em
seu coração.
Sílaba raam está circundada pelo mala de
mantra. À medida que o mantra recitado,
o mala de mantra começa a girar. A luz
que se irradia do mala forma oferendas
para os budas e bodissáas das 10
direções,
retornando como bênçãos de sabedoria.
Lua se irradia novamente para os seres
dos seis reinos, dissolvendo todo
sofrimento e transformando tudo nos
fenômenos imaculados da terra pura de
Tara.
Tra
solar.
[Música]
Tomar
tor
Táon
tá
tare
Tar
unar
Nós seguimos agora a nossa prática
dedicando à remoção de obstáculos e
longa vida das pessoas que a gente
queira lembrar especialmente
as pessoas vivas que a gente queira
lembrar especialmente.
Um taret só um tetão.
Ação tens
tensão.
Tad
F.
Tenção.
dançar
taret taret
on taretan.
[Música]
Nós seguimos a nossa prática. Agora nós
vamos dedicar a remoção de obstáculo das
pessoas falecidas, que a gente queira
lembrar especialmente,
que naturalmente nós vamos dedicar ao
Ricardo que tá no seu sétimo dia.
antes de seguir aqui, eu queria
agradecer a Sanga por esse tempo todo
nós em grupo a gente tem recitado
longamente, né, dedicado nossas práticas
longe. A ele. Eu agradeço essa
continuidade, essa amizade, assim, essa
dedicação. Isso fez super bem para ele.
Ele viu isso acontecendo, né? Ele viu
essa dedicação toda. Ele super se
animou, se alegrou com isso, né?
E também ele teve aqui, né? Nos visitou
aqui esse ano. Ele veio e teve essa
oportunidade de pessoalmente tá
presente, né? Foi super bonito isso,
assim. Então, quer queria agradecer a
Sangra
e por esse tempo todo, né? E eu não
consigo
agradecer um a um ainda. Eu recebi
muitas mensagens, muitas mensagens de
grupo também.
Eu toda que eu recebi, eu naquele
momento eu podia agradecer, agradecer,
mas tem uma uma lista grande que eu não
consegui ainda, né? E então eu agradeço
já daqui assim, né?
Um abraço grande paraas sangas dos
vários lugares onde eu passei agora
recentemente com, né? Espero retornar,
espero, enfim, ir a a à Espanha,
né? E então faltou esse esse trecho. Eu
acho que o pessoal da Espanha não tinha
muito mérito assim, então já não foi
possível
assim, mas mas super alegria por essa
por essa por estarmos juntos assim, né?
A gente se sentiu super amparado.
Agradeço mesmo.
Então nós vamos dedicar as pessoas
falecidas que a gente queira lembrar
especialmente né?
Do coração de Tara emana uma luz de
arco-íris para os seis reinos e para o
bardo, envolvendo as pessoas falecidas
onde quer que estejam, purificando o seu
karma e as infundindo com as bênçãos
radiantes de Tara. Suas formas se
transformem. Esferas de luz que se
dissolve na mente coração de Tara. Um
reino além dos ciclos de sofrimento, um
reino de absoluta pureza e felicidade.
Essa parte, pessoal, é uma parte que eu
acho assim muito comovente, por vezes
assim um pouco perturbadora também,
porque quando a gente diz assim que suas
formas se transformam em brilhantes
esferas de luz, eu acho bom brilhantes
esferas de luz, né? Mas enfim,
brilhantes esferas de luz. E e a pessoa
para onde é que foi? né? Aí aquilo fica
um pouco perturbado assim. Então a gente
precisa entender esse aspecto, né? E
também como que elas se transformam, né?
Então, na verdade elas se transformam na
nossa mente, porque nós passamos a
vê-las desse modo, né? Mas vocês
observem assim, por exemplo, nós já
fomos crianças pequenas, né? Todo mundo
aqui passou por isso, né? criança
pequena, criança maior, eh,
pré-adolescente, adolescente, etc. Nós
passamos por essas várias fases. Então,
a gente pensa: "E a criança que eu era,
onde é que ela tá?" Ela, o corpo já não
tá ali, né? Já não é esse, né? também a
forma pela qual nós operamos a nossa
mente, ela mudou totalmente. Mas nós não
estamos em luto porque ah, o o nosso
bebê não existe mais, a nossa criança
pequena não existe mais. E também as
várias etapas que a gente passou a gente
deixou, mas a gente não tá com uma
sensação de que, enfim, morreu alguém,
né? Então esse é o ponto da brilhante
esfera de luz. Ou seja, essa brilhante
esfera, ela ela anima cada uma das
aparências que a gente tá vivendo. Se a
gente olhar com cuidado, nós temos uma
sensação de continuidade e a
continuidade da
do ponto luminoso dessa brilhante esfera
que é capaz de construir realidades,
capaz de fazer coisas, né? capaz de
estabelecer relações e estabelecer
coisas que surgem excesso. Então, esse
aspecto luminoso, capaz de construir e
se engajar e manifestar identidades, ele
continua. Esse aspecto luminoso é o que
se mantém após, se mantém cada um dos
bardos e se mantém depois de vida e
morte.
Porque nós nessa vida nós morremos
várias vezes, mas essa brilhante esfera
de luz ela segue. Então nós precisamos
localizar isso, né? Então quando a gente
olha para as pessoas falecidas, melhor
não prendê-los na forma anterior. Do
mesmo modo que se nós estamos presos na
nossa forma infantil, na nossa forma
adolescente, pessoal, que tem uns que
ficam assim, né?
é melhor liberar isso, vocês entendem?
Aí nós não vamos pegar as pessoas e
prendê-las.
Às vezes tem algumas coisas
desafiadoras, assim, por exemplo, que eu
gosto de lembrar, né? A pessoa sonhou
com a sua mãe falecida, né? Eu acho que
é muito justo a gente perguntar, "Son eu
com a sua mãe, que idade mais ou menos
ela tinha quando ela, nessa aparência
que ela surgiu?" Ela tem uma idade,
então ela não é a mãe enquanto criança,
não é a mãe enquanto adolescente, é uma
mãe enquanto
uma certa idade, mas a mãe mudou muito
em cada uma etapa, cada uma dessas
etapas, né? Então é super importante que
a gente pense que quando nós olhamos
para essas nossas imagens que surgem de
nós mesmos, nós não temos uma imagem que
seja a titular.
mesmo a mãe, né, que a gente lembra da
mãe. Mãe, ela tinha que idade,
né? Assim, eu da minha mãe eu lembro
mais a etapa final dela, assim, né? Tá
certo? Porque a gente teve uma longa
vida juntos, né?
Mas enfim, eu lembro mais essa etapa
mais madura dela, assim, né? Assim. Mas
eu me relacionei com a minha mãe em
várias etapas. Ela já foi várias coisas
assim né?
Isso.
Então, nós não somos uma única, o único
ser. Nós estamos mudando. O que não muda
é brilhante esfera de luz. Esse é o
ponto. Esse ponto atravessa vida e
morte. Então, essa prática, essa é uma
lembrança. Isso eu vi Thiago do Ripochê,
é que eu não tive coragem de fazer essa
prática aqui, porque eu vou assustar
vocês depois de escrever essa prática.
Assim, o Thiago pegou uma bacia
com areia, um pauzinho fincado aqui, uma
imagem humana, um nome. Aí ele utilizou
isso para nós.
Do mesmo modo que eu olho para guru
pochê, digo guru pochê, a gente olha
para aquela imagem e diz: "Essa é a
pessoa falecida". Ele representa a
pessoa falecida. Agora, o que que nós
vamos fazer? Nós vamos queimar isso com
o nome e com tudo. Por quê? Porque ele
não é isso. Ele é uma brilhante esfera
de luz. Então, quando a gente queima
aquilo, nós queimamos a visão cármica.
Vocês entendem?
Nós queimamos a visão cármica, mas a
visão cármica para nós é muito cara. Ela
dói muito no nosso coração. Nós queremos
uma ligação com a visão cármica. Nós não
queremos ver o outro como uma brilhante
esfera de luz. Isso aí não serve para
nós. Nós queremos o outro.
Então isso é o karma que nos infelicita
e tranca também essa brilhante esfera de
luz que ela fica sempre vestida de uma
aparência como se tivesse sempre uma
evocação daquela aparência anterior, né?
É como uma mãe dizendo: "Eu gosto de
você, mas quando você era bebê, você era
muito melhor. Eu gostava mais do bebê do
que o que você é agora". Mas mamãe, eu
sou uma brilhante esfera de luz. Não,
mas eu gosto de você beber assim. Isso
não é uma boa ideia, pessoal. Vocês
entendem? É assim, então esses momentos
eles são graves assim, mas enfim. Aí
vocês imaginem assim
e assim nós dissolvemos esse essa
delusão aqui. Aqui dentro tá esse
delicadamente nós estamos dizendo isso,
né? Suas formas
se transformam em brilhantes esferas de
luz. Elas são vivas, pessoal.
que se dissolve na mente, coração de
Tara. Então, essas brilhantes esferas de
luz são a própria natureza búdica,
inseparável, presente em todos os seres.
Os seres, quando nós reconhecemos isso,
eles não são nem separáveis.
Então, aqui nós dizemos um reino além
dos ciclos de sofrimento, porque o
sofrimento se dá dentro das coisas
construídas.
Isso aqui é um reino além do ciclo do
sofrimento,
um reino de absoluta pureza e
felicidade.
Assim, se nós aspiramos a felicidade das
pessoas falecidas, a gente retira a
necessidade deles segurarem as
identidades e justificarem o que fizeram
e se pedir desculpa pelo aquilo que isso
ou aquilo, né, as várias circunstâncias
da vida. nós nós
liberamos os os seres disso, né?
Eventualmente nós temos a tendência a
colocar os filhos, as mães, pais no
altar, pessoal. As mães, de modo geral
nunca foram essa santidade completa
assim, né? Também não quero duvidar
disso, mas é assim, melhor não colocar
no altar, né? Mas a brilhante esfera de
luz, essa pode ir pro altar assim. Esse
é o ponto aqui. Se dissolve na mente
coração de Tara, né? É assim.
Então, do coração de Tara emana uma luz
de arco-íris para os seis reinos e para
o bardo, envolvendo as pessoas falecidas
onde quer que estejam, purificando seu
karma, as infundindo com as bênçãos
radiantes de Tara. Suas formas se
transform em brilhantes esferas de luz.
que se dissolvem na mente, coração de
Tara, um reino além dos ciclos de
sofrimento, um reino de absoluta pureza
e felicidade.
Tom
tão
tare torare
tanto
[Música]
Tomon
taré
toré.
тарета T sol
tare
tor
tón
Tra
[Música]
Tet
Tare
tón
Tra
[Música]
un tar
ah.
Que os méritos desse encontro se
expandam e toquem a todos. Que o Mestre
Universal da paz e da compaixão,
sua santidade da lailama,
>> todas as tradições que veiculam essa
mensagem tenho longa vida. Que todos
estejam a salvo de gerar pensamentos
negativos,
o obstáculo mais destrutivo
que esses pensamentos nunca surge em
nossa mente. E que todos os seres também
estejam livres de pensamentos negativos
ao longo de minhas muitas vidas e até
este momento, todas as virtudes que tem
alcançado,
inclusive os méritos gerados por esta
prática e todas as que vier a conseguir,
ofereço para o bem-estar dos seres
sencientes.
possam a doença, guerra, fome e
sofrimento diminuir para todos os seres,
enquanto sua sabedoria e compaixão
aumentam nesta em vidas futuras, possa
eu claramente perceber todas as
experiências como sendo tão
insubstanciais quanto o tecido do sonho
durante a noite e imediatamente
despertar para perceber a manifestação
de sabedoria pura. no surgir de cada
fenômeno, possa eu rapidamente alcançar
a iluminação,
>> sem cessar pelas
>> budas e bodissátuas em conjunto, seja
qual for a sua motivação, sua ação
benéfica e preces auspiciosas,
seja qual for a sua onisciência,
realizações de poderes benévolos. E seja
qual for a sua imensa sabedoria,
eu, que igualmente venho para beneficiar
os seres, rogo para que possa alcançar
as mesmas qualidades. neste exato
momento, possam nem mesmos
fome, guerra e sofrimento ser ouvidos
pelas pessoas e nações da terra, mas
possam sim sua conduta moral, mérito,
riqueza e prosperidade crescer e possam
a suprema bem-aventurança e bem-estar
surgir para ela.
[Música]
Obrigado, pessoal. Obrigado.
Obrigado Neia.
E a Bisa chegou com o Henrique, que ela
não tem apego nenhum esse menino.
Então,
tchau pessoal, um beijo grande.
>> Abraço.
>> Não é para vocês aqui, pros outros.
>> Obrigada Lama.
Juliana.
>> Obrigada Lama. Tchau.
>> João do Vale, um abraço grande, querido.
>> Um grande abraço, Lama.
>> Constância todo mundo aí.
Obrigada a Catarina. Obrigado Catarina.
Eu vi tua mensagem, eu não pude
responder. Obrigado.
>> Grande abraço.
Beijo.
>> A Sandra Fortes também. Alegria te ver.
>> Obrigado.
>> A Giane. Obrigado, Jeane. A Paula,
diretamente de Paris.
>> Beijo aí para teus meninos.
>> Eita.
>> Da terrinha aqui também. da terrinha,
das terrinha.
>> Então eu vou eu vou encerrar aqui a
transmissão.
Beijo grande.
>> Ab. Abraço, Lama.
>> Abraço, Lama.
>> Grande abraço, Lama.
>> Obrigado, Carmetinha. Sempre aí, Denise,
obrigado.
[Risadas]
Bom, querida. Boa noite, gente.
Beijo para todos aí no templo caminho do
meio.
Braço.
Beijo né?